die us-girls erfurt ist ein
flugzeugträger der superlative das
modernste kriegsschiffe
seine größe und ausstattung sind
spektakulären sie
mehr als zwölf jahre dauert der bau des
flugzeugträgers
dieses schiff hat ein gigantisches
potenzial
das kostet der rund 11 milliarden euro
das teuerste kriegsschiff das jemals
gebaut wurde
ausgestattet mit neuester technologie
wir können jetzt die kampfjets viel
schneller starten und im zielgebiet
einsetzen
sind mehr als 1000 menschen beteiligt
[Musik]
ich habe noch nie mit einem so neu
gewählten team zusammengearbeitet
sie alle verfolgen nur ein ziel die uss
ford soll das schiff der zukunft sein
die neue technologie könnte aber auch
versagen
gleich wird keine leichte aufgabe
der 22 juli 2017 im marinehafen norfolk
im us-bundesstaat virginia wird im
publikum der fortschrittlichste
flugzeugträger der us marine präsentiert
die us-girls erfurt
333 meter lang
78 meter breit fast 100000 tonnen schwer
ein flugplatz auf hohe see
[Musik]
nach mehr als 40 jahren
leute die höhe ist es folgt eine neue
generation moderner flugzeugträger ein
eine schwimmende fest um die den
anforderungen und bedrohungen der
modernen zeit gerecht werden soll kein
anderes schiff transportiert mehr
flugzeuge und waffensysteme
die uss ford hat eine gewaltige
kampfkraft von stellt bisherige
flugzeugträger in den schatten
[Musik]
dieses schiff soll ein symbol sein für
die militärische vormachtstellung der
usa
ein mobiler flughafen auf hoher see der
seine ganze kampfkraft auf jeden punkt
der welt richten kann
etwa 90 prozent der weltbevölkerung lebt
in einem umkreis von 150 kilometern von
einer kirche in ihrem park von einem
flugzeugträger kann man diese gebiete
erreichen und praktisch jedes
strategisch wichtige ziel in der welt
reisen
[Musik]
nach internationalem seerecht gelten die
ersten zwölf seemeilen vor der küste zum
hoheitsgewässer des jeweiligen landes
in diese zone dürfen die flugzeugträger
nicht eindringen
die us-marine bevorzugt auswärtsspiele
haring von unserer heimischen küste
sollen kämpfer möglichst ferngehalten
werden sowohl
eine kriegsflotte besteht aus mehreren
schiffen
kreutzer
zerstörer
boote
unterstützt durch ein versorgungsschiff
und eine kriegsflotte kann als gefechts
einheit sehr flexibel eingesetzt werden
um verschiedene aufgaben zu erfüllen
denken
die kräuter gehören zu den größten
kriegsschiffen der us marine
sie führen fast 10.000 tonnen munition
an bord
verteilt auf verschiedenste waffensystem
die zerstörer sind schnell wirklich und
effektiv
sie sind mit tomahawk marschflugkörpern
ausgestattet
raketen mit einem 500 kilogramm
sprengkopf und einer reichweite von bis
zu 1600 kilometer
in der nähe der flotte kreis doch immer
ein u-boot auf der suche nach
feindlichen schiffen und anderen geboten
mit an bord mag 48 torpedos mit jeweils
300 kilogramm sprengstoff
das versorgungsschiff sorgt für
nachschub
ob essen
treibstoff
oder munition
die zentrale rolle in der flotte spielt
jedoch der flugzeugträger
träger haben die größte kaufkraft an
bord und sind daher auch anders
dar um bezeichnet einen flugzeugträger
auch als kapital kriegsschiffe weil die
mensch ist kapital in sie investiert
wurde
es gibt weltweit nur 19 flugzeugträger
zehn davon gehören den usa
die usa bauen die meisten flugzeugträger
aber andere länder hätten auch die
einrichtung ab
bereits im zweiten weltkrieg zeigt sich
wie wichtig flugzeugträger sind
ende des zweiten weltkriegs hatten wir
fast 100 flugzeugträger sie alle
zusammenhalten nicht mal annähernd die
schlagkraft von nur einem modernen
1955 bilde die typenreihe forstall die
erste generation der super träger
die forestle waren die ersten
flugzeugträger die mehr als 75.000 toms
waren daher die bezeichnung super träger
mit ihnen konnte man zum ersten mal mit
atomwaffen bestückt
[Musik]
sechs jahre später folgt die reihe
khedira
und das modell enterprise ab
1975 werden zehn flugzeugträger der
reihe nichts gebaut ihre kampfflugzeuge
erreichen
die billigen ort der welt
während des kalten krieges sind immer
mindestens 15 flugzeugträger
einsatzbereit
der fall der berliner mauer leitet das
ende des kalten krieges ein ab 1993
werden die ersten flugzeugträger aus der
flotte gezogen und verschrottet
die us navy befürchtet ihre aufgaben
nicht mehr erfüllen zu können
wie die navy hat traditionell zwei
standorte für ihre flugzeugträger zum
einen im persischen golf bzw im
indischen ozean zum anderen im vest
pazifischen ozean
[Musik]
beide regionen sind von den usa sehr
weit entfernt
um dort ständig präsent zu sein benötigt
die navy eine ganze reihe
zwei sind vor ort
sie habe zwei abgelöst die nach hause
fahren ein anderer ist auf dem weg zum
einsatzort zwei werden gerade
aufgearbeitet
zwei weitere sind in der wartung und
einer ist in der vierjährigen komplett
überholung mit der uss ford werden
insgesamt elf flugzeugträger für
ständige präsenz sorgen das sind die
fakten ärzte mehr
anfang dieses jahrtausends erweisen sich
die älteren flugzeugträger als technisch
überholt
irgendwann kommt die zeit da bringt es
nichts mehr die schiffe weiter zu
reparieren unter dem strich ist ein
neubau günstiger horst
flugzeugträger halten etwa 50 jahre
die navy ingenieure bestanden darauf
endlich eine neue reihe zu entfernen
2008 ist es soweit der us-kongress
beauftragt den bau eines neuen
flugzeugträger typen mit dem namen fort
die ford typenreihe ist nach dem
präsidenten gerald ford benannt der im
zweiten weltkrieg als marineoffizier
flugzeugträger werden traditionell nach
ehemaligen präsidenten benannt der
kongress erwartet die auslieferung des
super trägers im jahr 2015 der bau des
teuersten schiffs der weltgeschichte
kann beginnen
newport news im us bundesstaat virginia
in dieser schiffswerft soll das neue
flaggschiff der us marine entstehen
schon seit dem ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts werden hier kriegsschiffe
für die us-marine gefertigt
keine andere werft auf der welt kann so
große flugzeugträger
wir bauen seit den 1930 ein
flugzeugträger im laufe der jahrzehnte
haben wir die bauweise perfektion
die schiffswerft ist über
220 hektar groß mehr als 20.000 menschen
bauen hier tag und nacht schiffe
70 prozent aller us kriegsschiffe
stammen aus dieser werft
[Musik]
herzstück der anlage ist das trockendock
nummer 12 mit 670 meter länge und 76
meter breite eines der größten weltweit
im november 2009 beginnt der bau der iss
fort mit dem schiffsboden
[Musik]
nach drei jahren ist das fertige schiff
nur zu erahnen
in dieser bauphase wird vor allem
schwerer stahl verarbeitet überall
liegen stahlseile die wir tag für tag
zusammenschweißen wir sind jetzt beim
dritten deck angelangt das schon über
wasser haben wird aber es liegt noch ein
langer weg vor uns
2000 tonnen stahl mehr als 4000
kilometer kabel und
90.000 rohrverbindungen müssen in dem
schiff verbaut werden
ein gigantisches unternehmen
die chip ist das schiff besteht aus
millionen von einzelteilen wir verbauen
eine unglaubliche menge an material
rund 5000 zulieferer aus dem gesamten
land versorgen die werften mitteilen und
material
heute wird eine ladung stahl geliefert
die werkhalle für die stahlarbeiten
gehört zu den größten weltweit hier
würden ungefähr zehn fußballfelder
reinpassen
die halle gibt es seit den 1800 80er
jahren
heute stehen hier die modernsten
schwerindustrie maschinen die es auf dem
markt
für den bau des neuen super trägers
investierte die werft 600 millionen euro
in hightech maschinen
das ist eine von ihnen sie presst
vertiefungen in den dicken stahl als
wäre das zeigt
das ist unsere mächtigsten
eine presskraft von 5
diese presse entwickelt so viel kraft
dass sie 2000 solcher pickups stemmen
könnte die vertiefungen dienen später
dazu die jets auf dem flugdeck zu
sichern
7000 solcher vertiefungen müssen
gepresst werden
die schweren stahlplatten für die neuen
flugzeugträger herzustellen wurde diese
anlage gekauft sie ist so groß dass sie
die gesamten walz vorgänge in einem
ablauf schafft ein echter fortschritt
[Musik]
sind die stahlplatten gewalzt kommen sie
auf dieses gelände hier werden die
einzelteile zu kammern
zusammengeschweißt
diese werden zum modulen vereint so
schreitet der aufbau des chefs stück für
stück voran
die methode ist nicht neu wohl aber die
ausmaße es sind die größten und
schwersten module die je für einen
flugzeugträger montiert wurden
module kann aus 20 30 oder 40 kann
bestehen befinden sich dann schallt
räume pumpen räume lagerräume oder
abschnitte eines fahrstuhls
sobald die module stehen werden die
mechanischen und elektrischen
komponenten angebracht
wir verlegen die kabel installieren
elektrische bauteile die
belüftungsanlage die maschine mit schiri
eben alles was ins schiff gehört
diese bauteile nennen die schiffsbauer
super lift extrem schwere module sie
wiegen zwischen 80 und 900 tonnen so
viel wie ein einfamilienhaus mit im bild
manche super lift module sind zwei bis
drei monaten fertig für andere brauchen
wir über ein jahr
das super lift modul wird schließlich
zum doc transportiert um es mit den
bereits fertigen schiffsteilen zu
verbinden
dahinter steckt eine perfekte
choreografie
der zusammenbau es bis ins kleinste
detail durchgeplant manche vergleichen
das mit legosteinen
an diesem tag steht eine der größten
herausforderungen bevor das schiffs heck
anzubringen es wiegt 932 tonnen und
besteht aus 32 modulen
80 tausend arbeitsstunden stecken allein
in diesem schiffsteil da drin steckt
eine menge an ausstattung die
lenkgetriebe die stromverteilung einige
tanks und ein paar lager
die massive heck konstruktion soll am
nächsten morgen mit dem rumpf verbunden
werden ist sie einmal angehoben gibt es
kein zurück mehr
die schiffsbauer dürfen sich keinen
fehler erlauben
so einem großen bauteil kann ein kleiner
fehler schlimme folgen nach sich ziehen
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen bereiten sich die
werftarbeiter auf ihre heikle aufgabe
vor
die verbindung des fast 1000 tonnen
schweren hex mit dem rumpf
dazu nutzen sie einen besonderen
lastenkran den big blue der aspekt der
big blue clan ist das symbol unserer
werft er wurde beim bau fast alle
unserer super träger eingesetzt er ist
so groß man sieht ihn schon von weitem
[Musik]
big blue ist ein brücken kran die werft
besitzt einen der größten auf der ganzen
welt
auf jeder seite des docks verlaufen
schienen auf denen der kran über die
gesamte länge des schiffs entlang fährt
um seine ladung zur gewünschten stelle
transportiert
der kran ist 71 meter hoch und wiegt
rund
4500 tonnen
wurde in den 70er jahren gebaut und hat
eine ladekapazität von 900 tonnen als
wir den auftrag für die vor drei
erhielten wussten wir aus dem kran
können wir noch mehr rausholen
er verfügt über drei wenden wenn man sie
richtig positioniert schafft jede sogar
350 tonnen so können wir über 1000
tonnen
der letzte check steht an die ingenieure
kontrollieren das heck es hängt bereits
am kran und ist auf zwölf stahlträgern
aufgebockt wir haben vor zwei tagen das
deck angehoben und auf die träger
gestellt da spart uns heute zeit für den
langen transport zum
in 70 metern höhe bringt der kranfahrer
big blue in position
dutzende werftarbeiter stehen bereit für
den notfall
für diesen bauabschnitt stellen wir
besonders viele mitarbeiter bereit um
sicherzustellen dass alles wie geplant
abläuft wir überlassen nichts dem zufall
[Musik]
wir achten sehr darauf dass sich niemand
unter dem schiffsteil befindet wir
wollen jedes risiko so weit wie möglich
ausschließen
nach einer stunde ist das heck an rumpf
angebracht
das schiff ist nun zu 50 prozent
fertiggestellt
das ist schon ein tolles gefühl
man sieht was man als team erreicht hat
um einen flugzeugträger zu bauen braucht
man einen echt langen atem
nach zwei weiteren jahren und 162 grad
transporten ist es soweit der
gigantische stahlkörper erhält sein
zentrales nervensystem die
kommandozentrale
611 tonnen schwer die modernste ihrer
art
das kommandozentrum jedes
flugzeugträgers wird auch die insel
genannt
auf sieben stockwerken arbeiten dutzende
marinesoldaten vom verbandsführer
bis zur flugkontrolle
hier koordiniert der airbus start und
landung der kampfjets
die insel ist ein kontrollturm mit
kommando
luftraumüberwachung und
antennen
die insel steht auf dem flugdeck
doch das war nicht immer so
die ersten flugzeugträger sind umgebaute
frachter oder kreuzfahrtschiffe sie
besitzen noch keine kommandos
die schiffe waren gar nicht als
flugzeugträger konzipiert
dann setzt er einfach ein flugdeck
darüber
damit sind die ersten mobilen start und
landebahnen auf hohe see geschaffen
aber die pioniere stoßen bald an ihre
grenzen
wie jeder flughafen seinen tower hat
braucht auch ein flugzeugträger ein
kontrollzentrum
wie soll man ohne brücke starts und
landungen und all die herumfliegenden
flugzeuge koordinieren
die dach landebahn konstruktion führt zu
einem weiteren problem
sie versperrt dem kapitän die sicht
unter dem flugdeck steuerte er quasi
blind durch das meer
sie brauchten dringend eine lösung und
das war die insel
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg werden nur
noch flugzeugträger mit insel gebaut die
befindet sich immer an der
steuerbordseite
die insel auf der uss ford ist halb so
groß sie die ihre vorgänger der nimitz
klasse und weiter hinten platziert
den unterschied zwischen dem us- es ford
und einem niemetz schiff erkennt selbst
ein laie auf den ersten blick sieht
die neue position vergrößert die fläche
des flugzeugs vor der brücke um und 2000
quadratmeter also etwa acht tennisplätze
dadurch entsteht mehr platz für die jets
wir können die flugzeuge viel schneller
in startposition bringen und so 30
prozent mehr einsätze fliegen
nach dem einbau der insel ist die uss
ford zu 96 prozent fertiggestellt
die produktion für das schwesterschiff
uss kennedy läuft bereits auf hochtouren
doch im us-kongress stößt das projekt
zunehmend auf kritik das budget für die
uss sind erfurt wurde bereits um mehr
als eine milliarde euro überzogen
eine tonne stehen ich will wissen warum
die navy die kontrolle über die
kostenfreie ohren hat
ich weigere mich weitere gelder für den
zweiten flugzeugträger zu bewilligen
solange die navy und die werften kosten
nicht in griff bekommen
nicht nur im kongress werden zweifellos
selbst im umfeld der us marine gibt es
experten die die eingeschlagene
strategie für falsch halten
ich bin mir durchaus bewusst wie sehr
die flugzeugträger zum erfolg der nebel
in den letzten 70 jahren beigetragen
haben aber
hält man sich heute ihre effizienz vor
augen ist ihre zeit abgelaufen
während die us marine auf die
flugzeugträger setzt entwickeln andere
länder waffen um diese zu zerstören
die gefährlichste ist die chinesische
dongfeng 21 ein schiffs killer sie
schafft in weniger als zwölf minuten
rund 2000 kilometer
ihr sprengkopf kann mit einem schlag
einen flugzeugträger versenken mitsamt
seinen hochmodernen kampfjets
kritiker meinen wegen der entwicklung
immer neue angriffs raketen seien
flugzeugträger schlichtweg nicht mehr
zeitgemäß
2012 vier jahre nach dem baustart steht
das prestige-projekt der us marine auf
der kippe
sind die tage der super träger gezählt
oder können die navy und die werft das
gegenteil beweisen
die baukosten laufen aus dem ruder
und befeuern die argumente der kritiker
sie sind der meinung die us marine
sollte die produktion einstellen die
teure super träger seien nicht für die
moderne kriegsführung gewappnet
aber im pentagon finde das projekt
starke befürworter sie fuhren
gegenargumente
so wie die anderen immer bessere
angriffs systeme entwickeln werden wir
entsprechend bessere abwehr system
entwickelt
die uss foto 2 raketensysteme
beide können angreifen die raketen und
flugzeuge ausschalten
für einen nahkampf ist der
flugzeugträger auch gerüstet
der sogenannte sieges ist mit
panzerbrechende munition geladen
[Musik]
er feuert in der minute
4500 kunden ab
die us-marine arbeitet an einer waffe
die sechs hochintensive leser zu einem
gewaltigen energie strahl bündelt
der kann gezielt schiffs sensoren
zerstören
raketen und sprengstoff auf feindlichen
schiffen zünden
oder unbemannte drohnen zerstören
und dann gibt es noch die schienen
kanone
stadt mit schießpulver werden die
projektile mit hilfe elektromagnetischer
antriebskraft hinauskatapultiert
sie erreichen 6 fache
schallgeschwindigkeit und durchdringen
starben
es wäre ein leichtes eine oder mehrere
dieser waffen auf einem flugzeugträger
zu installieren
während der kongress noch über den neuen
super träger debattiert arbeitet die
werft mit hochdruck an der
fertigstellung die schiffsbauer glauben
die kritiker am besten dadurch
überzeugen zu können indem sie das
schiff endlich fertig stellen
auch wenn der ein oder andere zweifel
aufkamen haben wir die herausforderung
angenommen wir wussten ja von anfang an
dass es nicht einfach werden würde nur
keiner von denen die am bau der uss ford
beteiligt sind stellt sich die frage was
bei der arbeit schief gehen könnte jeder
hier gibt sein möglichstes um das beste
chef zu bauen ist
keine leichte aufgabe
im oktober 2013 ist es schließlich
soweit
das trockendock wird geflutet
die torte des namensgebenden präsidenten
susan fortbildung öffnet die schleusen
380 millionen liter wasser strömen ins
trockendock
es dauert fast einen ganzen tag bis es
geflutet ist und das erste exemplar der
neuen flugzeugträger klasse schwimmt
einen monat später die schiffstaufe
ich hoffe das schiff auf den namen
gott beschütze das schiff und seine
mannschaft
das ist jedes mal ein tolles gefühl wenn
die flasche am schiff zerschellt dann
weiß man gleich wird es zum ersten mal
in see stechen man hatte einen
entscheidenden anteil daran
die uss fortfährt zu einem anderen teil
der werft bevor der super träger in
dienst gestellt werden kann stehen ihnen
noch einige testläufe bevor
nach dem stapellauf ist das schiff noch
lange nicht in gefechtsbereitschaft
das ist noch ein langer prozess
dafür gehen
der flugzeugträger steht vor der größten
bewährungsprobe
werden seine neuen technischen systeme
die erwartungen erfüllen
die beiden neuheiten die für die meisten
diskussionen sorgten waren das katapult
und abbremst einrichtung für die jets
wenn diese systeme nicht wie geplant
funktionieren kann die uss ford ihren
zweck nicht erfüllen
flugzeugträger haben primär eine aufgabe
den einsatz von kampfflugzeugen rund um
den globus zu ermöglichen
aber das können schon die schiffe der
älteren nimitz klasse sehr gut sie
liegen am tag hunderte von kilometern
zurück
die herausforderung liegt in der
optimierung von starts und landungen
ein kampfjet benötigt an land eine
ungefähr 3000 meter lange startbahn ja
sowas gibt es auch flugzeugträger
natürlich nicht
aus unsere startbahn ist höchstens 332
also brauchen die kampfjets eine
unterstützung um für den stapi nötige
geschwindigkeit von etwa 280 kilometer
pro stunde zu erreichen
dafür sorgt das katapult kerpen
die frühen kampfflugzeuge sind
wesentlich kleiner
auch die bomben liegen nicht so viel
daher können sie aus eigener kraft vom
träger aus
in den familien über den zweiten
weltkrieg sieht man das sehr gut wir
nennen das techcrunch
die flieger starten vom flug deck des
trägers auf die gleiche weise wie von
einem normalen flug fällt
sie brauchten grundsätzlich keine
unterstützung durch ein katapult
in den 50ern sind die flugzeuge schon
größer und traten mehr und wesentlich
schwerere bomben an bord
in der nachkriegszeit ging es vor allem
darum die flugzeugträger mit mehr
kampfkraft auszurichten
man brachte für die schweren flugzeuge
eine effektive starthilfe das führte in
den 50 jahren zur entwicklung des dampf
katar puls
seit 1955 ist jeder flugzeugträger mit
einem dampf katapult ausgestattet
doch das dampf katapult hat auch
nachteile
der dampf entwickelt brutale kräfte
die load und maschine werden in nur drei
sekunden von null auf 280 kilometer pro
stunde katapultiert
beim katapultstart wirken enorme kräfte
auf das flugzeug und die waffensysteme
mit der zeit entstehen dadurch schäden
repariert werden müssen das kostet geld
und man muss ausfallzeiten in kauf
nehmen
da werden tonnen von material
schlagartig in bewegung gesetzt
eine sehr wartungsintensive technik man
braucht eine menge personal die unter
dem flugdeck das dampf katapult bedient
und in schuss
ein weiteres problem die dampf katapulte
lassen sich nicht auf die modernen viel
leichteren flugzeuge der zukunft an
wänden und
wir reden hier von unbemannten
kampfdrohnen die vielseitig einsetzbar
sind von denen könnte man viel mehr auf
einem träger unterbringen weil sie
wesentlich kleiner und leichter sind die
uss ford musste ihn entwicklungen der
zukunft gerecht werden
wenn heute zwölfjähriges kind später
ingenieur wird und seinen traum von
einem flugobjekt umsetzt das uns dient
dann wollen wir in der lage sein ich das
starten zu lassen
die uss ford ist nach 50 jahren das
erste schiff führt dass ein völlig neues
system zum start der flugzeuge entworfen
wurde das sogenannte imis ein
elektromagnetisches katapult es sollen
mehr starts ermöglichen dabei seine
kraft schonende entfalten und mit
weniger wartung auskommen das herzstück
bildet der sogenannte
linearmotor er besteht aus einem fest
stehenden teil den fixierten schienen
und einem beweglichen teil dem zug
schlitten an dem der jet eingehackt wird
erst mit 160 magneten versehen entlang
der schienen verlaufen elektrische
spulen sie werden nacheinander unter
spannung gesetzt und erzeugen
magnetfelder die den schlitten von einer
spur zur nächsten antreiben und den jet
in den himmel katapultieren
die magnetspulen werden ständig umgepolt
so dass die vordere spiele den schlitten
anzieht und die hinter ihm gleichzeitig
abstößt bis zum ende der rampe
vor dem stapellauf hat die navy das neue
katapult bereits vier jahre lang an land
getestet
zunächst mit einer super hornet vom typ
f a 18
standard kampfjet der us marine
danach mit einer 26 tonnen schweren z2
aj greyhound maschine
und schließlich mit dem neuen jet f 35
lightning tun
die sterns mit dem neuen katapult 10
zunächst vielversprechend aus doch 2014
gibt die us-marine das ergebnis der
testphase bekannt jeder zehnte start mit
dem neuen katapult miss land ein
gewaltiger rückschlag der das ford
träger projekt ins wanken bringt
ein schiff von dem aus keine flugzeuge
starten können ist schlecht für uns und
für die navy
wenn die elektromagnetischen katapulte
nicht funktionieren ist der ganze
flugzeugträger wertlos
kenia hat ein problem der teuerste und
modernste flugzeugträger der welt
erweist sich möglicherweise als
milliardengrab
die schiffsbauer suchen mit allen
mitteln nach einer lösung aber die zeit
läuft ihnen davon und die kosten
explodieren
das problem liegt die vorderreihe stellt
insofern eine ausnahme dar als früh
entschieden wurde schon den prototypen
mit revolutionären technologien
auszustatten bei so einem projekt sollte
man davon ausgehen dass es immer wieder
zu rückschlägen kommen kann aber
auch die lande fondsanlage bereitet
probleme
flugzeugträger sind einzig darauf
ausgerichtet möglichst viele starts und
landungen zu ermöglichen wie viele
einsätze schafft man an einem tag darauf
kommt es letztlich an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf einem schiff zu landen gehört zu den
schwierigsten herausforderungen für
einen kampfpiloten
der pilot soll auf einer bahn landen die
in bewegungen ist nicht nur
die landebahn weicht in der regel um 15
daher muss der pilot im landeanflug
ständig etwas nach rechts korrigieren
auf den ersten flugzeugträgern werden
die flieger mit hilfe von fan seite
abgebremst die über das deck gespannt
sind die
ersten brems helfen waren noch seile die
zwischen sandsäcke gespannt wurden und
die der pilot mit einem fang hatten am
tag erwischen
später wurde dann als kabel system
eingeführt bei dem die freilegung schiff
eingebaut sind
das prinzip ist aber das gleiche nur
bremsen die fang saale heute jets ab die
mit 240 kilometer pro stunde landen
für die landung muss der pilot den fang
haken ausfahren und damit eines der drei
kabel auf dem deck treffen beim
aufsetzen gibt der vollen schub
im falle eines fehlschlags wieder
durchstarten zu können sobald der haken
am kabel hängt wird der jet sofort haben
gebremst erst jetzt zahlte der pilot die
triebwerke in leerlauf die kabelenden
sind mit einem hydrauliksystem unter dem
deck verbunden
die hydraulikzylinder absolvieren die
energie schon noch zwei sekunden kommt
der jet zum stehen ein zuverlässiges und
effektives system eine f a 18 hornet
landet hier viermal so schnell wie an
land
aber die enormen kräfte die beim
abrupten bremsen auf den jet wirken
hinterlassen spuren
es gab über die jahre immer wieder
einige verbesserungen an dem
hydrauliksystem und auch in den fang
seilen aber das physikalische prinzip
blieb immer das gleiche
es gab zwar neue ansätze aber die
umsetzung wäre zu teuer gewesen und dann
entwickelte eine firma ein völlig
neuartiges bremssystem das ist jetzt
unsere neue landebahn
für das personal und die piloten ändert
sich dadurch nichts am ablauf des
landeanflugs
die neue lg lande fall anlage arbeitet
immer noch nach demselben prinzip mit
dem fang sein auf dem der
doch die technik darunter ist komplett
die kabel sind mit zwei trommeln unter
dem flugdeck verbunden
sobald die kabel vom jet herausgezogen
werden bremst ein elektromagnetischer
motor das flugzeug gleichmäßig ab
unterstützt von wasserturbinen die die
energie absorbieren das system passt die
brenz stärke automatisch an je nach
gewicht und geschwindigkeit des
landenden jets maximum beim neuen system
sollen weniger kräfte auf das fluc werk
werden unterm strich bedeutet das dass
die jets weniger schaden nehmen und
damit eine längere lebensdauer haben
das ist aber nur theorie in der praxis
treten erneut gravierende mängel auf
und die entwicklungskosten belaufen sich
am ende auf mehr als eine milliarde euro
sechsmal so hoch wie anfangs kalkuliert
die us marine steht unter druck sie muss
beweisen dass wenigstens einige der
neuen technologien ihr geld wert sind
im juni 2015 will die us marine vor
medienvertretern beweisen dass das neue
elektro magnetischer katapult inzwischen
zuverlässig funktioniert
zur demonstration soll ein großer
stahlkörper vom bug des flugzeugträgers
abgefeuert werden der stahlkörper wiegt
6800 kilogramm etwa ein drittel des
gewichts einer voll beladenen f18 der
stahlkörper simuliert ein kampfflugzeug
keine museen ob die geschwindigkeit des
katapult ausreicht und das ganze system
funktioniert
verläuft der test erfolgreich könnte das
dem umstrittenen programm zu neuem
schwung verhelfen
andernfalls wäre es ein erneuter
rückschlag
wenn es schief gehen sollte müssen wir
damit fertig
und dafür sorgen dass es funktioniert
gleich ist es soweit
der stahlkörper wird an den zug
schlitten eines der elektromagnetischen
katapulte eingehakt
jetzt wird sich erweisen ob das neue
start system bereit ist um in betrieb zu
gehen
susan fort bis die tochter des
ex-präsidenten gibt das startkommando
der schlitten erreicht nach 90 metern
eine geschwindigkeit von 260 kilometern
in der stunde
und schießt den stahlkörper in den fluss
das war der beweis dass das neue
katapult funktioniert und endlich
eingesetzt werden kann
für und schiffsbauer war das ein großer
tag
[Musik]
damit haben wir bewiesen dass wir in der
lage sind die neue technologien zu
entwickeln zu bauen und auch einzusetzen
[Musik]
ein jahr später gibt es auch einen
durchbruch mit dem neuen lande vom
system
eine f a 18 super hornet wird bei einem
test zwölf mal sicher abgebremst
wir konnten zeigen was wir schon immer
wussten es funktioniert der chef kann
jetzt den see stechen und wir sind stolz
darauf
im juli 2017 ist die us-marine von der
neuen technologie überzeugt und nimmt
den flugzeugträger in ihre flotte auf
die uss gerold erfurt ist der elfte
flugzeugträger der us flotte und der
erste einer völlig neuen generation
es ist ein feierlicher tag für den
kapitän die gesamte besatzung der
jackpot von diesem tag an ist dass kein
schiffbauprojekt mehr sondern ein
aktives kriegsschiff mit einer
mannschaft
[Applaus]
in diesem schiff steckt eine
riesenleistung
wir sind in den jahren an unsere grenzen
gestoßen es gibt keine größere
herausforderung für einen chef bauer
über die nächsten drei jahre
für die mannschaft der ford jedes
einzelne system des schiffs gründlich
prüfen
diese testphase ist noch einmal wichtig
um zu beweisen dass das schiff im
ernstfall einsatzbereit ist
denn wenn der tag des ersten einsatzes
kommt wird es ein unglaublich effektives
schiff sein
in der werft ist unterdessen das zweite
schiff der reihe bereits zu 50 prozent
fertiggestellt die uss kennedy
von diesem wissen konnten wir dann bei
der uss kennedy profitieren
die kennedy soll im juni
2022 ausgeliefert werden scheint noch
eine lange zeit bis dahin
total aber wir arbeiten jeden tag hart
daran
der us-kongress hat mittlerweile drei
weitere flugzeugträger bewilligt für
insgesamt fast 50 milliarden euro
der bau der iss fort wird sicher in die
geschichte eingehen als ein meilenstein
des schiffsbaus
aber es muss sich noch erweisen ob der
modernste flugzeugträger der welt gegen
die bedrohungen des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts gewappnet sein wird
wir finden immer einen weg
text es kostet zeit und viel geld aber
ich glaube der aufwand hat sich gelohnt
[Musik]
die anfangsschwierigkeiten hat die uss
ford hinter sich gelassen nun muss sich
der gigantische flugzeug
den weltmeeren
weißen